everybody was going on played here I'm
here at CBS 2news
and we're Conan is going to learn how to
be an anchor from a legendary anchorman
Bill Kurtis and Walter Jacobsen so let's
go behind the seeds
[Music]
all right can't where are we what are we
doing we are at CBS News Chicago there
are two newscasters here
Bill Curtis Walter Jacobsen they've been
at it since I was a little baby
you know tonight Conan is gonna go learn
from the best on how to be a newscaster
maybe show them a trick or two
[Music]
okay web
[Music]
you guys so glad I'd love to see nothing
on what do you want to do I figure maybe
you could just be at the set and we'll
run 50 things you ever spend a lot of
time here that's I have yes I spend some
time here in 1988 Ellie yeah lived in
reason with that okay
[Music]
for the beginning of this news patch
we're going to try right now let's all
be turned away we'll all turn together
that would be our signature it's never
been done three anchors altering at the
same time into these cats this will make
right that's mystery
good evening I'm Bill Curtis I'm Walter
Jameson and I'm Colonel of Brian
beginning with the developing story
the Chicago bomb squad just gave the
all-clear in Wrigleyville they spent the
afternoon evacuating buildings after
report of a live grenade
let's maybe end a newscast right now you
say good night you say good night I'll
say garner Brian we linked arms
we salute how are you gonna link arms
and smoothen see oh you'll see that's
our new son Bill Curtis and I'm Walter
Dickerson I'm Connor Brian and that's
the way it is I'm Bill Curtis and that's
a wrap
you